I used to listen to people asking for
help that's what I was trying to do is
help people but I was fooling myself
darkness only responds to darkness
I'm daredevil I have made many mistakes
but I accept the debt I beg because of
them
Prison has changed me what is it you say
I want to make a deal
these claiming to have changed but they
don't know him like I do the last time
that we spoke you threatened to me that
is something that I cannot forgive not
stopping for good this time
it's only one way to stop me but you're
not gonna do it you sure about that
just be careful that you don't become
the monster
because I tried to make this city a
better place
to tell the world who you really are
someone who's now showing his true
colors
sometimes you have to help on precious
it's a greater good
he needs a new villain I think I might
have found him daredevil is our true
public enemy
according to eyewitnesses the brutal
attack has been carried out by not
everything
daredevil
[Music]
who are you I'm daredevil
hey everybody is Charlie a surprise
surprise new daredevil trailer a couple
days early obviously they're doing born
again you probably detected on a bunch
of the big comic book Easter eggs and
the fake daredevil who's being played by
the person that we all think that was
playing bullseye headed into the season
what a crazy coincidence that he can
land all those crazy quick shots with
the Escrima sticks because of venom and
all the Marvel stuff happening this week
we're still doing the spider-man ps4
game giveaway all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video on him a new
winner at the end of this the trailer
opens with a really iconic comic book
panel of daredevil holding the cross on
the steeple he's talking about what he
used to be what he's becoming during the
season he needs to embrace the devil of
Hell's Kitchen persona and leave behind
the daredevil that he was trying to be
before they actually explained the real
reason why he's wearing the black
costume isn't because he doesn't feel
like he deserves to wear the regular
daredevil costume there was even some
weird trickery where it looks like he's
fighting Melvin Potter in his workshop
there like you see him swing that blade
at him then you see Melvin Potter later
in the trailer closing the gate on him
while he's touching his old daredevil
costume he's so messed up in the head
this might have something to do with the
fake daredevil going around hurting
people so he might be confused about
Matt being the person that's actually
hurting people and not the fake version
of daredevil when he's in the church the
interesting thing too like you think
he's in fatherland hubs Church but then
you see the person holding the rosary
beads has fingernail polish that's
Matt's mother Maggie from the comics but
Charlie Cox himself said that they would
be doing something interesting with
their relationship they did clarify that
the convent where he winds up at the end
of defenders he actually grew up in this
convent so remember all the flashbacks
from season 1 when he was a kid when
stick came to visit him at the convent
that was where mother Maggie works so
it's the same place where he grew up no
idea how he wound up there at the end of
defenders maybe Elektra took him there
because I do think that she's still
alive no idea when she's gonna come back
because there's so much stuff happening
during season 3 most of the scenes that
you see him even early in the trailer
where he's wearing the new black costume
it's actually a new one I mean he goes
back to
the old style of black costume but he
cobbles together a new one
in the basement of the convent with
stuff that he finds there so all the
people that he fights once he's in the
black costume are probably people
working for Fisk or the FBI because Fisk
has the FBI thinking the daredevil is
the real criminal here I'm a changed man
so I love the fog ease reaction when he
sees that Fisk gets out the showrunner
explained that the reason why he gets
out of prison is because he finds out
that Vanessa is going to be implicated
in all of his crimes so he wants to keep
Vaness out of prison he strikes a deal
with the FBI to inform on other
criminals in the city so you see part of
his masked Nations he's the kingpin of
crime-- and he's going to slowly take
over the city by getting rid of the
competition and by using this fake
version of daredevil played by the
bullseye character so the crazy thing is
is like you see this picture here of him
in the halfway house like this place
where he is staring at the white wall
that's meant to be like the white
painting that Vanessa gave him this is
where he goes after the FBI lets him out
of prison
but while he is still informing for them
so even though he's out of prison he's
not completely scot-free but when he
says he's a changed man you can sense
the born-again metaphor like he puts the
white kingpin comic book suit on because
he's normally wearing black the way that
Catholicism and religious metaphors are
so important for the series I mean it's
really about daredevil being born again
but I love the twist on it that they're
using for the kingpin character which is
not something from the comics there's
obviously a whole bunch of comic book
changes here kingpin sounds like he has
a phone call or a meeting with Matt
Murdock in broad daylight and references
daredevil season 2 when Matt says
there's nothing that you can do to hide
from me we can go find Vanessa and throw
her in prison and that was really what
set kingpin off it was threatening
Vanessa so when he's saying you
threatened me I can't let that stand
that's what he's referencing so that's
why he's coming after Matt Murdock but
then later through the course of the
season and probably as the FBI search to
go after him he probably figures out
that he's daredevil because you see him
sitting in the chair here with kingpins
standing over him show the city who you
really are and then he stands up and
turns around to clock him like he's
wearing his black costume with the mask
off so
however they get to that moment there is
no question that kingpin knows who
daredevil is it'll be interesting to see
even though I expect daredevil to end
the season on a high be born again
quote-unquote what they do with kingpin
going forward because when a villain
that powerful knows who you are it makes
a really interesting situation day to
day between the fights that you have
like what is daredevil gonna do by the
end of the season that's gonna prevent
kingpin from just turning right back
around and coming after him and all of
his friends most of the last part of the
trailer is dedicated to teasing the fake
daredevil bull's eye character so the
whole thing here I think I explained it
in a couple of my previous daredevil
videos about the fake daredevil from the
born-again title it was actually two
different characters in the comic book
so what happened is is once kingpin
found out Daredevils real identity he
separately hired a deranged mental
patient to dress up like daredevil just
a random mental crazy person to go
around and start killing people then
separately he also hired will Simpson
the new character remember from Jessica
Jones season two to just go down and
straight up kill Matt Murdock so what
they've done for the TV show I think is
a big upgrade they've used the bull's
eye character to combine all those
separate characters what's gonna happen
next is as Chris Evans just dropped his
final goodbye to the Captain America
character so everybody's making this
Will Ferrell face just crying into their
drinks right now so we'll do video for
that next that should be up in the next
couple of hours there's a whole bunch of
stuff happening so I'll just post
schedule updates in the top pin comment
so just check that out for what's coming
next
congratulations Kyle Sinclair you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for my non-spoilery venom review
and click here for that new spider-man
trailer that they drop thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you